cuando se les pregunta a muchas de las
personas que están en este momento en
esta plaza o que le hemos preguntado que
sienten después de haber sido liberados
o que las fuerzas ucranianas hayan
retomado otra vez el control de la
ciudad y a todos se les dibuja una gran
sonrisa pero a partir de ahí lo que
cuentan son muchísimas tragedias de
estos ocho meses en control de las
fuerzas rusas nos hablan del temor que
tenían de salir a la calle y ser
detenido algunos nos cuentan que sus
familiares lo fueron y que incluso están
desaparecidos y también nos cuentan de
las dificultades que están viviendo
actualmente no tienen electricidad no
tienen agua aquí en este momento hay
miles de personas que están tratando de
cargar sus celulares en plantas
eléctricas que se han habilitado también
otros recogiendo comida y también esas
tarjetas de teléfono del celular porque
durante muchos meses lo que ellos
utilizaron fueron
rusas y todo esto está rodeado por el
sonido de las explosiones de las fuerzas
rusas que están a menos de un kilómetro
de aquí al otro lado del río y esto está
en constante presencia en esta Plaza hay
muchos niños nos cuentan los traumas que
tienen cada vez que suena una explosión
esto ha sido su vida en los últimos ocho
meses Así que dicen que la única manera
como esto puede solucionarse es si
logran expulsar o hacer retroceder a los
rusos aún más